Allah says in surah is chapter number 17
verse number 17
that we have honored the children of
Adam both men and women.
When we refer to the scriptures of other
religion some other religions
they blame
the woman for the original sin.
If you read the Bible
in Genesis chapter number three,
Eve is individually blamed for
disobeying God and eating the forbidden
food, eating the forbidden fruit.
If you read the Quran
in surah arav chapter number 7 verse
number 19 to 27 Adam and Eve peace be
upon them they addressed more than a
dozen times
and the Quran says both of them
disobeyed God. Both asked for
forgiveness. Both repented and Allah
forgave both. The blame is equally put
on both of them. There is not a single
verse in the Quran where Eve may Allah
be pleased with her is addressed alone.
But there is one verse in the Quran
surah taha chapter number 20 verse
number 121 where Adam peace be upon him
is singled out and addressed and he's
alone mentioned that he disobeyed Allah.
But there is not a single verse in the
Quran where Eve alone may Allah be pleas
with her is singled out and said that
she disobeyed Allah. But on the whole if
you read
we come to know that both of them
disobeyed Allah both repented and both
were forgiven.
But in Christianity the blame is put
100% on the woman.
And further if you read in Genesis
chapter number 3 verse number 16 It says
God says to the woman, I will multiply
your conception
and in pain will you give birth
and your desire shall be your husband
and he will rule you.
I'm repeating if you read the book of
Genesis chapter number 3 verse number 16
it says Almighty God says I will
multiply your conception as though
pregnancy is a curse on the woman
and you will give birth in pain as
though pain is a punishment for the
woman for disobeying God
and your husband will rule over you
and your desire shall be of your husband
and he will rule over you. In Islam,
pregnancy is not a punishment. In fact,
pregnancy uplifts the woman. The Quran
says in surah nisa chapter 4 verse
number one, respect the womb that bore
you.
Pregnancy does not degrade a woman, it
uplifts the woman. And there are several
verses and several hadith
in which because of pregnancy the woman
is uplifted.
Allah says in the Quran in surah Lman
chapter number 31 verse number 14 we
have enjoined on the human beings to be
kind to the parents in travel upon
travel did the mother b you and in years
twain was the winning. Allah repeats the
message in surah hak chapter number 46
verse number 15. We have enjoyed the
human beings to be good to the parents.
In pain did the mother bow you and in
pain did she give you birth. So here
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala uplift the
woman because of pregnancy.
So if you analyze the spiritual rights
of the women in Islam,
the rights of the men and women,
they're equal
and Allah says in the Quran
and points out the criteria for Allah to
judge a human being
is tawa.
Allah says in the Quran in surah chapter
49 verse number 13.
Oh humankind, we have created you from a
single pair of male and female and have
divided you into nations and tribes so
that you shall recognize each other. Not
that you shall despise each other. And
the most honored in the sight of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala is the person who
has tawa.
The criteria for judgment in the sight
of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala, it's not
sex, it's not gender, it's not wealth,
it's not color, it's not race, it is
tawa, it's God consciousness, it's
piety, it's righteousness.
So this verse clearly shows
that sex and gender is not the criteria
for Allah to put someone superior or
degrade someone.